conny island dans les années 1950
sa plage sa promenade je suis
surveillant de baignade et c'est là que
carolina en français s'il vous plaît
vous savez si tu dis là c'est moi donné
je suis la fille d'anne dit vous êtes sa
femme alors là il va pas en revenir
bien qu outre à supporter il faut que tu
faut pas s'étonner quand on a épousé un
gangster et une fois vers nantes et sage
en ce moment la demoiselle booba rester
sur la plage une annonce de la foudre
évidemment quand on impose un type qui
fait fortune en mitraillant tout ce qui
bouge on touche peu un avis elle alors
ta femme elle aime plus à la pêche quand
il a fait comme si qu'elle est mais pour
que je mordre à l'hameçon
toutefois depuis
tu sais qui est un contrat sur sa tête
tous croient pas qu'il devrait partir
je sais qu'elle cada brison dans leur
bac et celle en bronze et pratique
énerve comme ça moi je vais là coincée
certains gourine dans mon crâne c'est
fini tout s'effondre tu t'es vu tu
ressembles à une folle
[Musique]
en matière d'amour on est finalement
bien souvent son pire ennemi
je sais parfaitement ce que tu as fait
tu n'as pas l'impression de légèrement
dramatiser
[Musique]